[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذا الموجز انتهت الهدنه
الاحاديه التي اعلنتها موسكو واكد خلالها
الجيش الروسي التزامه بوقف اطلاق النار
لكن سلطات الاوكرانيه نفت وجود اي هدنه
وقالت ان الجيش الروسي واصل القتال على
محور بخبط بينما اعلن الجيش الروسي تقدم
قوته في مدينه سردار الاستراتيجيه في
دنياز شرقي الولاده
واقالتكافنا المدينه ما زالت تحت
السيطراتها
واضافتناها قصفت اربعه وعشرين
للجيش الروسي ومنظومه صاروخيه
تنطلقوا اليوم في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم المرحله النهائيه للعمليه
السياسيه في السودان وقد قالت لي الثلاثيه
التي تتولى الترتيب للحوار في السودان
والمشكله من الاتحاد الافريقي ومجموعه
ايجاد وبعثه الامم المتحده قالت ان هذه
المرحله سيحضرها المدنيون والعسكريون
المواقعون على اتفاق الايثار السياسي كما
هو ضحى تلاليه ان المشاورات تتركز على خمس
قضايا على مدى اربعه ايام لدراسه خريطه
طريق لاحياء عمليه تفكيك ما يعرف بتمكين
نظام البشير
الغى وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي تصاريح
التنقل لي ثلاثه من كبار المسؤولين
الفلسطينيين بعد زيارتهم لعميد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين المحرر كريم يونس وقد شمل
القرار كلا من رئيس المجلس الوطني
روحي فتوحه ونائب رئيس حركه فتح محمود
العلوله وعضو اللجنه المركزيه في فتح عزام
الاحمد وسبقان اعلنت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
صاحب تصاريح شخصيات فلسطينيه مهمه منهم
وزير الخارجيه واحدوا مستشار الرئيس عباس
ومندوب فلسطين الدائم في الامم المتحده
وذلك ضمن اجراءات الانتقاميه بعد توجه
السلطه الفلسطينيه الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تظهر الاف الاسرائيليين في تل ابيب
احتجاجا على التغيرات القانونيه التي
تجريها حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو على النظام
القانوني والقضائي في اسرائيل ورفع
المتظاهرون شعارات مناوئه لنتنياهو حكومته
الجديده ووصف اجراءاتها بالانقلاب على
الدستوري والديمقراطيه كما شارك في
المسيره عددا من اعضاء الكنيست عرب
اسرائيل
فتحت الصين اليوم حدودها بعد مضيف ثلاث
سنوات على القيود التي فرضتها بسبب
جائتكورونا واطبقا للقرار الجديد يتعين
على القادمين الى الصين اذار اختبار سلبي
لفيروس كورونا خلال يومين قبل موعد الوصول
وتتزامن هذه الاجراءات مع استعدادات
الصينيين للاحتفال براس السنه القمريه
الجديده حسب التقويم الصيني
الى اللقاء